okay here we go again and mr. serious I
remember some weird nope he played some
kind of check benoni reverse by had a
fantastic position but he avoids there
now okay we're going to play Queens
gambit accepted and this is an opening
that I'm currently trying a little bit
with I don't really know the lines yet
but like to see something different once
in a while and okay Bishop f7 have to
address castles that some so much the
same way to and play this position I
think here I can just develop more
aggressive is aged three or queen bee
three those kind of ideas on 93 where
the the option of age of three ng for is
still kept alive here g4 is quite
unlikely to happen and I'll see 5 is I
think I'm very good equalizing try okay
I can take yeah interesting here hmm
trading probably yes the Queen has got a
good square there unknown and e2 but you
still think that should be very very
fine for black I can develop easily you
form maybe 45
it could have been somewhat tricky
after Bishop did to that distance not so
much of a problem he 45 I was a bit
afraid of that but okay he plays it in a
more conservative way okay i think i'm
going to control b5 and play Queen B 6
next maybe it's still shooting for you
45 to be honest hmm I should've paid
more attention to that not sure that I
could have done something against it but
I should have have had a look yeah Queen
B 6 that was my idea at least now for
Knight e5 is possible
the main purpose of Queen B 6 was just
to connect rooks yeah there's no big
idea to activate the queen or whatever
the black Queen doesn't have a good post
there I don't mind to put it on be aid
for example that's no big problem just
needed to connect looks
I'm not sure what probably doesn't have
anything brilliant going on for him here
I wonder if I'm able to play b5 wife
that is helping me at all be 596 i can
probably take the knight Knight takes
rook takes be takes a 4 but it's got
rope takes a six then I'm not sure about
okay just just goes back yeah any way
forward here night some 95 I think I
should do this anyway cover the
eighth-ranked so that sometimes I can
take on c1 play rook c8 and I still have
those 9594 ideas mm-hmm that is taking a
very long time here quite surprised i
will see ever going to and make a make a
time time here um k goes back to f3 yeah
maybe be five now so that after after
years remove the night
Wow
yeah that kind of mean I'm taking a long
time in those games sometimes but it is
usually in position where there's
actually something going on I mean he's
basically letting the clock run down in
a nothing happens position it's kind of
a kind of amazing okay so matt is a
pizza active and I want a try to and
maybe get a bishop to have six as well
okay guys got 95 mm okay I can let's do
this first light c6 Queen Queen B 6s
Bishop f5 mmm weird ok gotcha simplify
stuff now okay maybe and grab this
it's got 96 million yeah but ok after
Queen to see several nice let's to take
with the porno okay hmm this should be
Forza is a tricky move very tricky move
for the check on his seven all of the
Sun oh ok I did not want to go to the
six ok
I'm just happy if I don't loose material
here it's uh yeah now he's speeding up
but time is a big mess though hmm i have
to take check no Queen da de is no other
way hmm what about this potentially
hanging him everything is potentially
hanging here rookie a desperate e6 I
shouldn't do that and I'm one light
needs some stability I don't know where
to put it Queen I'm sorry right at five
that's probably the Queen comin to you
five
okay head towards f6 wow I will lose on
time I am NOT going to offer enjoy it
just too silly I mean well this time
management is really ridiculous for a
fence on time like never like spending
going out down to 50 seconds and 20
moves when nothing ever happens yeah I
don't know I mean I absolutely am I mean
I've thought about the time the time
thing in those games and the way I'm
going going with this now and you can
send me your feedback if you like the
may I'm going at this now so i'll simply
stop complaining about people playing on
time as really is it's really pointless
i really learned that it's pointless
they will and whining about that makes
no sense but I also see no sense and
gifting away half points if they kill
themselves on time um yeah I'll just
take that and and it's okay I mean I'm
not going to do anything totally
ridiculous i like playing rook against
Luke for 43 minutes because i have 10
seconds more on the clock but if that
time management is this is really awful
like that i'll just take the point that
i'm okay with it um yeah i think there
was not much happening in this game it
was pretty equal ish for a very very
long time i tried a little bit there to
get activity but i think aaron and yeah
it was what's really interesting way to
play um okay yeah the computers it's
always pointing out interesting ideas
strong move yeah
and everything works perfectly together
I didn't consider and now I'm in bad
shape who should be for you would've won
and I have no good to way to cover it
you know but he had no time he was down
to 20 seconds I mean the way it went he
also was better yeah well I don't have
anything great i mean this isn't taught
this isn't isn't brilliant but didn't
see anything and then also clearly worse
in the final position but yeah yeah well
what can you do this is just too much of
a suicidal time management to just give
it away draws all the time okay thanks
for watching